bill doesn't understand why her
boyfriend's Furious after her spring
break trip she went on spring break
he found out saw some things he said I'm
mad she doesn't get why let's just watch
it's safe to say that this man was way
too insecure and let other people get
the best of him uh in his emotions
whatever whatever he's feeling I'm not
cheating I'm not doing anything that's
like foul or wrong I'm just literally
having a good time but besties taking a
shot body shot off of me and yeah
because I'm in Rosarito and they put a
[__] sticker on my teeth and that's
one but the second one
I'm like dancing with another one of the
workers because he was a Vibe and a
board of Sean in my mouth flipped me
around
I mean yeah I danced with the [__]
worker you know he's mad because this
guy's actually cute or like is he
jealous like
but okay I guess for like a submissive
boring [__] yeah that's wrong like
issue like wait hold on I didn't think I
was doing anything wrong
so there's nothing to say you don't
think you did you don't think you did
anything wrong I'm not even gonna argue
with you you don't think you can't
understand that we're not even
we're playing a game not even the same
rules you don't see anything wrong with
that and then it is it's fine if you
you're not really willing to have the
conversation at least have the
conversation because she's like nah I
did nothing then I mean okay like yeah
okay you can call your boyfriend
whatever you want to call him you do you
do you but at the end of the day it's
like you guys are not even playing the
same game it's wild there's nothing to
say really go your way and let him be
mad the way you mad I think he dodged
one and that's cool
I'd be mad at the fact that you don't
want to have the conversation and the
fact that you don't see it hypothetical
you come home someone sends you videos
and you see your girl doing that what
you doing you got a whole ass talk yeah
I talk like what we have to have a talk
after I have a whole last talk I don't
even know but you have to have a talk
and then I have to see what what what
connects and what doesn't connect what
you acknowledge what you don't
acknowledge you understand what I'm
saying what was that
you see what I'm saying I'm Gonna Keep
it a stack with you
that's a fireable offense no
conversation and I say this only because
of this it's multiple videos over an
extended period like that ain't just the
[__] cheated that is she don't respect
you that's what that is you don't
respect somebody and do something like
that in public on camera and sound like
she does you know that's a that's a
that's a Donovan sharp pack the bags
once she come out the bathroom after she
take a [__] that's one of them once I
don't see that for much
I don't see that for much but this one
I think that's an immediate fire I
understand what you're saying uh I'm at
the conversation point and and to be
fair and to be honest with you even
having a conversation I don't know what
you're gonna be able to say but you want
to at least hear it you wanna hear it
not even sure yeah
yeah magicians in them [__] straight
up straight jackets and and they gotta
break themselves out yeah let me see you
pull some magic I I know I know what's
gonna happen I expected the room there's
no dwarves under the chair there's no
magic string there's a trick you ain't
got no keys on you you see you do it yay
there's a trip let me see let me see you
do it yeah so what so yeah question go
ahead
you getting some breakup [__]
wow I'm not gonna lie this is gonna feel
it break up sex kind of fire I can't
understand but when the breakup says and
when in the back of your mind the
breakup says is already broken up or
broken into okay it's like you know what
I mean you know when you're supposed to
when you buy a car where you gotta buy a
performance car you're not supposed to
go in like pedal to the metal already
you have to break you know you have to
break it in yeah yeah but when your
[__] already been broken you don't feel
like I'm I'm not gonna use that cars are
that's not brand new partially but
here's the thing what's up I've been on
both ends of the being the best you know
I was wrong in the relationship yeah and
both times the breakup sex was fire of
course yeah
[__] you yeah yeah it's [__] you [__]
all of a sudden you get you you get away
with a few slaps in the face
hey
he told you about Abba and slapping
white woman in the face
that's you oh no no no no my slap
history is United Nations
we all participating and also let's be
clear when I [__] up I was on the
receiving guy and that was good too
okay listen
I wouldn't know yo last time I took a
plane this is what they gave me yeah
this wonderful little bundle of joy the
problem with those is that you can't
hear nothing uh it always itches in my
ear so you know what I mean
what I use now when I travel is the
raycon earbuds it comes with five
different types of gel uh there's an
awareness mode there's a noise isolating
mode as well so you can perfectly hear
the sound that comes out of those
earbuds and the other competitors far
too expensive we offer the premium sound
at half the price and not only that but
they're also water resistant yeah
yeah when I travel it's when I train too
it's water resistant because I'm
sweating and everything and stuff and
they don't fall off
look let me show you
see
where you at go to the link in the
description below or go to buy recon.com
Abba to get 15 off on us I think this is
super trashy I want in a little bit of a
light note but is there anything else
you want to see no no
God forbid I hope you never have to try
it but if you do it
you know talk about it
all of a sudden they sucking like
they're trying to save the relationship
like the remedies in the end they give
that guy got five thousand you
understand like it's an upgraded version
that's some funny they hope if they pull
it out of you they also going to pull
out the memories of the [__] [__]
they did funny [__] yeah and you busted
nuts in the wrong places just to be like
oh yeah yes I'm so the same this is a
busting nuts in different kinds of
places no that's not what the [__] you
said you said you busting nuts in all
the wrong places wrong places around
there the wrong places
I feel like I'm being baited yes this
feels so wildly inappropriate I feel
like I'm being baited by someone
like this doesn't even seem like a real
post yeah but you don't believe any post
is real
yeah
I know I know what you did that's you
but this is what feels like baked this
one is this one is so out there if
you're doing your private parts are out
on camera I'm open-minded
I don't think I'll ever be that
open-minded
I'm open-minded too I'm come from the
culture of caribana and Carrie Fiesta
and and Carnival and Soca and one Panda
girl you know I mean uh daggerated all
them stuff there I come from that
Caribbean culture so I could be open to
a lot of things however all my boobs are
out did he just put a sticker on it you
minimal you minimize so much everything
that there's nothing to argue you ready
to know what the real problem with this
is it's not even what happened on camera
it's what led to them being so
comfortable to do that on camera yeah
that they do in that in public you get
what I'm saying yeah cause no man just
grab a random girl from behind lift
their neck up and start pouring drinks
out of her face nobody nobody lives
the tongue to put a sticker underneath
like that that means a lot before that
y'all doing the most that's a lot of
times y'all doing the most you let
another man grab you from behind like
that but no bend you over like that then
play under your yo yo
I can understand I can understand being
being him being mad but if you don't
even acknowledge that there's nothing
there's nothing to also that vocal fry
voices is not for me
you don't really like that one people
you don't like the vine you don't like
when people learn so much
no look you know what it is like if you
want to be for this week that's fine go
pay the suit of your electric bill and
keep it pushing but don't be out here
talking about you in a relationship
while you out here looking like your
relationship with the next man too
that's weird to me
because I couldn't tell who you were
committed to I do know in spring break
you weren't committed to him because
that looks us
she was bent over by two dudes getting
spit roasted
in public
and what did he say at the end about the
submissive woman yeah she's not gonna be
a bun Bishop miss a woman that's gonna
like you know I had nothing to be
submissive I had nothing to do with that
that is that is nothing she's not gonna
take no for an answer you know I'm
without you I ain't got much commentary
for this one there's no commentary it's
just like what commentary are you gonna
have to someone that can't you can't
even have you can't even conversate with
the person you can't even have a
conversation with the [__]
what's up yeah you you can't there's no
if if I at the base of everything
okay
you don't even recognize
that there was something that was off
about this we can't talk yeah that's a
lie that's a lot that's a lot even if
you're single that was a lot even if
you're sick yeah that's a lot in a short
video
even if you're single so it's like man
whatever there's nothing to say one
there's no commentary about that what
commentary do you want ref